how's gone Brett mine is purify well
come back to some RM that [ __ ] back out
I shed I got one I should be more
careful probably can't go in here it's
locked
we got the code now at least so maybe
the one of these doors has a code on it
yep it's a good thing I put that code on
my memory
all right in Sierre well is the [ __ ]
code uh yes yes yes yes five six two
nine five six two nine five six two
nights five six two nine five six Turner
five six two nine five six two nine five
six two nine five six two nine five six
two nine come on
I [ __ ] you wait how many how many
paintings of women I have to count that
hold ah this place Quattro Cinque assay
ha already check
okay I can't the counter more than that
11 11 12 13 14 I don't know if that
[ __ ] counts that [ __ ] oh come on that
it was a sound whoa
yes yes give me life I had AG window
crash these galleries spooky music park
it's so much fun playing here the day
was over before I knew it
why isn't fantastic why weren't you down
here you'll be finding a lot of this
company please don't touch to this place
if you by any chance damage
ah [ __ ]
I swear to god it was this password my
that's stupid
did I really get it mixed up again ah
[ __ ] shut up shut up lady why you're sad
bruh five sing high six tonight
yeah it's upside down I'm an idiot
[ __ ] ah that was a good puzzle though
I'm so stupid sometimes
alright I need to see it if I'm gonna
have to get an idea uh so six
five I guess
nine to
one six two nine nine five it's [ __ ]
six two nine five six two nine five six
two nine five six two nine five six -
[ __ ] nine five six two nine yeah [ __ ]
yeah that's how I roll
that shouldn't have been that difficult
what are you doing right are ya doin
there's no one around but you feel a
presence where do you want to go there
with this ah [ __ ] me what are you doin
here no it wasn't Gary
no it wasn't son-of-a-bitch Gary alright
what's going on in here huh mirror oh
it's us I'm so short all right what huh
that is creepy why you nice
was I supposed to do something stop back
stop it that's funny
what I shed all rights guarding that
thing pretty well isn't it let's go
ahead and say oh oh oh it's fat that's
bad all right here we go yes yes huh
bloody catch the catch huh oh this is my
parents I don't know ah they do resemble
you I bed but why would such a painting
me down here well I can't I don't know
anything
ah this is going to be tough for me if
your child why not rest
you'll never be heard again I don't
trust that what what did I do
huh feels good
am i waiting for something
okay what's going on here
all right
that didn't really do anything didn't
alright let's move it to the other
[ __ ] up gosh huh I don't like this
huh
shed a [ __ ] ah [ __ ] they told me to rest
my [ __ ]
ah why not I thought I was opposed to
alright let's try that again
it's not it really quick cuz I don't
know [ __ ] scared me
alright [ __ ] we gotta get the key you
gotta get the key we gotta get the key
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] stop stop I hate those
paintings [ __ ] hate the paintings
alright uh it says this if you're tired
why not rest you'll never be hurt again
I think that alright move it to the
other yeah now they can't come in from
there oh I get it and we need to cover
the hole somehow right we can't really
do that can we
uh whatever all right yeah yeah okay we
get wet Matt shut up shut up Mike here
we go ah [ __ ] so [ __ ] creepy alright
let's try to sit down ah
come on I don't know what to do about
this thing can I move this am I supposed
to go
ah come on can a [ __ ] I can go in here
strapped okay we need to go there we
need to go to heaven easy for that go go
go go
yeah I may hate you I hate you so much
your guys suck what I'm saying man ah
sure that would be far enough I think
are you sad Mischa come on I did yep Oh
are you okay em em ever even whatever my
scar done I have to end this episode but
it's so intense
oh my god what huh huh what huh
fireworks oh [ __ ] ah ah back it up back
in that shed they touch my ass
so [ __ ] creepy ah okay we woke up
where they're having a nightmare
ah sorry key it's right I have a
nightmare
I see you poor thing can't say I'm
surprised being exposed to much trifle
thing I got is good you woke up and saw
it and do it anyway AB would you take a
look in this pocket of that coat it's a
piece of candy
ah afraid to eat it that's rest here a
while longer but we sat out again I
decide sweater man
did I sleep inside of a seal I think
some poor dead seal loved the music
I love the music love this game it's
awesome anyway like a finishing during
this episode sky comes rushing in let's
sing except so whatever night celebrant
dad said stop oh ha ha
what is this awesome music oh my god